[MUSIC PLAYING]
PRAKASH KAMATH: Hey, Brian.
BRIAN SUK: Oh, I
didn't see you there.
Oh, you scared the
heck out of me.
Sorry.
I was just busy--
focused-- trying to
build this sculpture
with all these building
blocks that we have.
The problem is is
it's so unstable,
and it keeps falling over,
and I spend so much time
trying to maintain and
build these things.
PRAKASH KAMATH: I
know someone who
has just the same problem
with compute resources.
They tried Hadoop, but it fails
often and is super expensive.
BRIAN SUK: Ah, there must be a
better way, some sort of tool
that builds all these things
for us and maintains it,
so we can spend more
time analyzing and doing
the things that we love, instead
of spending all of our time
building and maintaining.
PRAKASH KAMATH: Hmm.
TOGETHER: Dataproc.
PRAKASH KAMATH: You know what?
I have just the thing.
BRIAN SUK: Nice.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
PRAKASH KAMATH:
Let me show you how
to create a large Dataproc
cluster with preemptible nodes
using the Google Cloud
console with just a command
line in minutes.
First, we'll create the cluster.
We'll give the cluster a name.
Then we'll pick a
place to put it.
We are in New York,
so we'll pick US-East.
Next, we get to choose
the cluster mode.
And there are three choices.
For this demo, we'll
go with Standard.
After that, we get to pick
the shape of the master node.
We'll go with 2 vCPUs.
We'll set the primary
disk to 10 GB, which
happens to be the minimum.
Then we get to customize the
shape of the worker nodes.
And you'll see, it's really
easy to customize the shape.
And this was really important
for a customer of mine.
We'll set the primary
disk size to 10 GB, again.
And we're creating a
really large cluster
with preemptible nodes, so let's
configure the preemptible nodes
next.
We'll set the number
of nodes to 400,
and the shape of these nodes
will match the primary worker
nodes.
Now, we could create the cluster
right to this user interface,
or what we can use is the REST
command that it auto-generates,
or even the gcloud command,
which is also auto-generated.
Now, because I want to
measure the time it takes
to create this cluster,
I have a little script
that we'll run
using Cloud Shell.
And that'll create the
cluster for us today.
Now, as this cluster
is being provisioned,
we can actually
track the progress
through this user interface.
So we could go up and
click on the Clusters,
and you'll see about 400 nodes
being provisioned as we speak.
You can click through
and go to the Details.
Look at the VM Instance
list, and you'll
see all of these preemptible
nodes getting provisioned.
Now, a few things
about you using
preemptibles in your cluster--
they help you run very large
clusters at a low total cost.
The machine type of
these preemptible nodes
matches the machine type
of the primary workers.
Now, within a Dataproc
cluster, preemptible instances
are added to a managed
instance group.
And as you know, they can be
reclaimed at any point of time.
So these instances
can be re-added back
into the cluster if and
when capacity is available.
Also, a few things to
consider about preemptibles,
they're used as processing nodes
only and do not store data.
By default,
preemptible nodes are
created with the
smaller of 100 GB
or the size of the primary
node's persistent disk.
And this is, again, used
only for local caching
and is not available for HDFS.
Also, you cannot create
a Dataproc cluster with
preemptible-only nodes.
At minimum, a Dataproc cluster
will have two primary nodes.
This ensures that the cluster
will never run out of workers.
You can add or
remove preemptibles
from a cluster as
needed, and even
set the number of preemptibles
in a cluster to 0.
50% or lower of the total number
of worker being preemptible
is a good working ratio.
As you can see, the cluster
is now ready for use,
and it only took a
couple of minutes.
And you can even
submit your jobs
through this user interface.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRIAN SUK: Oh, thank
you for showing us.
That's really cool.
So what you're
telling me is that
with a few clicks
of the mouse, we
can easily set up
these large clusters
that build and heal themselves.
Also, I really do love that
it's super quick to do,
and it doesn't take ages
to set up and build,
like it did when I used to
have to do this by hand.
But my blocks, my poor blocks.
Don't you have
anything out there
that will build this for me?
PRAKASH KAMATH: Well, Brian,
we can't build your blocks
for you.
But what you just saw
were the building blocks
for big data analytics.
BRIAN SUK: That is really cool.
Thank you so much for watching.
And remember to click
Subscribe and share this video.
PRAKASH KAMATH: And if you're
working on any cool projects,
connect with us by clicking
on the link in the description
below.
[SINGLE XYLOPHONE TONE
REPEATING]
[SLOW SWOOSHING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]